in the beginning there was nothing well  actually there was a lot of stuff but it  was boring and then there was the broken  podcast on one side the sexy Swede known  as PewDiePie on the other the American  gear a cinnamon toast Ken and the  podcast was so good it brought light  into this dark and toxic world who wrote  this that's a bit intense don't you  think anyway it welcomes special guests  like markiplier jacksepticeye crime and  international Rockstar President Obama  that last one is a lie there were cables  challenges and conversations so  legendary that the animals still sing of  their glory what whatever now a broken  podcast is making history once again  coming to sling TV so get ready to  experience a pro fost like you've never  experienced before and you better watch  because if you don't then the robots  will win that last one is also a lie  maybe the broken podcast available now  on sling TV